let me just say this you are the only
person that i would watch one of these
movies for i do not do scary movies i do
not do gory movies
at all i was sitting there like i'm
gonna kill
chris watching this movie last night
you're filming these scenes with these
traps and these like really gruesome
deaths what is that like
you know what you have to remind
yourself it's not really happening
because you watch it even when you're
close you see the blood and you're like
huh
like are they killing a stuntman just to
get the shot
but uh they assure you that it's fake
right i hope it's fake
and yeah it's it's r it's actually
scarier there
so like on those really crazy gruesome
days
do you shower right after or are you
like walking around target
or wherever looking just real crazy
nash i shower right yeah there's yeah
there's days where you're just
soaked in blood yes yeah you look like
carrie
i don't know they're hours not days how
can i catch this guy
if there's nobody on the bus i can fuss
you can't do this alone
whoever did this has another motive
something personal
and i wonder if we're all crazy people
because these films have been around so
long and people really love them like
what does that say about us but what do
you think
the reason is why people take to these
movies so much i mean they
they they always they take it up a notch
i mean
you gotta watch you know you know
there's some good ones just seven of
them and you know
number two is my favorite but uh yeah
they just go
up a notch in a notch in a notch and
you're like whoa
they're like roller coaster rides you
know they're just
when you're on a roller coaster
sometimes you're happy and sometimes
you're cursing out the roller coaster
and then you want to do it again
you know i was cursing a lot of people
last night because i was like why
god why do i have to watch this
detectives are really keen on their
intuition
like they follow that gut really good do
you have a good gut do you follow your
gut well and
are you like the the main detective
between your two girls like can you
figure out
who's like not telling the truth who's
trying to get one over on dad or are you
just
done uh yeah it's always when you're a
detective
and a comedian are very similar
because you you study human behavior
you like you can't do it without kind of
being a semi expert on human behavior
right so yeah i'm kind of knowing my
girls a lot
that i don't yeah do you let him get
away with it or you like calling him out
immediately
no sometimes you gotta
sometimes you call them out immediately
to go into a shell
yeah sometimes you got to let them kind
of let them know like
i know you're lying but we're going to
deal with i'm not even going to say
you're lying but let's
and then later on they'll come on and
they'll go okay i'm sorry daddy i
shouldn't have done
whatever i love it so you know max's
max is kind of coming into his own as a
leading man
um in this film in a lot of ways but
you're cementing 20 years
as a leading man the first movie that
really kind of made
us say well okay come on chris rock
first on the call sheet was down to
earth like
20 years ago with regina king so what do
you what do you remember about shooting
that film and then shooting that film
with her and kind of
how did it make you look differently at
your career when you said chris
oscar winner oscar winner
regina king uh wow that was so
long ago yeah uh we had a ball
regina was lovely every time i see her
we
we it's it's like we didn't miss a day
uh i don't know i don't even know what
to say i
was one of that was like my first
starring movie and it was just all magic
at the time
from now on we got a new slogan shot in
the head
you get a bed okay if your head is
bloody we're your buddy
did you know at all what you were doing
i didn't know anything
i was just so glad to be there i didn't
you know i was
it's one of those things too looks like
uh overstudy so i knew everybody's lines
you know because i was just oh will
smith said he used to do that too
because he was so scared because he
wasn't a good actor and he used to know
everybody's lines and he would mouth
them you could see him in the scenes
like
people were saying that he'd be sitting
there mouthing other people
yeah i definitely had such a fear
of not knowing you know hey
of being called out but not knowing my
line so yeah i
i get it well i get it i'm here to help
reform the metro police
to remind them of their oath to the
people of this city
one officer from your station refused to
be reformed
he will not be the last to play my game
some of the themes in this film are very
kind of relevant to what we're seeing
today chris that's you know
crooked cops a broken system did they
have to
update this from the book at all or was
that already
there i mean unfortunately a lot of this
was
already there wow i mean
you know a lot of stuff that's happening
now
you know you know the reality is we're
only talking about it because it's on
film but the stuff's been
you know we're talking about it because
of cell phone cameras but the reality is
these things have been happening
for hundreds of years
so yeah a lot of this stuff was just in
the script we did not have to like
update it because of
current events i could have killed you
what are you talking about i got the gun
i could have killed you how did you get
in here
you forget who the landlord is yeah but
that doesn't give you the right to just
walk in here anytime you want
renter's got rights you start paying
some rent you can get some rights
so you did make me laugh out loud in a
couple places though especially when you
were telling the joke about why cops get
divorced
600 tuesdays ain't worth three saturday
nights and i was like oh he's not lying
though
i'm a woman he's not lying he's not
lying at all
so then what is your best tip because
actors have even crazier schedules a lot
of times than cops what's your best tip
to try to make it work oh god i'm
michelle i'm
single i do not i do not i obviously
don't know how to make it work
try your best
love heart michelle this is love hog so
i want to ask you about your next
project because you got this david
o'russell comedy coming up with like a
list of
wow a-listers right what can you tell me
about this
at all i'm sworn to secrecy all like you
know
chris it's miss detroit come on robbie
uh robert de niro christian bale uh
romy malek yeah mike ma it's this crazy
cast
we had an amazing time david o'russell
is my favorite director wow and
i'm gonna be in all his movies from now
on whether he wants me in them or not
i'm just gonna show up to the set here's
what i'll say
this is an inside thing okay i initially
had about
i'm gonna say four or five days that's
how big my part was
right it ended up being about 23 days
don't let us find out that you came in
and just acted your ass off in this
hotel yeah it was like
every day i was like determined to make
sure the teacher liked me
so good so i came in there ready to play
i
definitely came in there ready to play
and he was great
so him and i had a great rapport uh
i can't wait to see the movie i can't
wait to work with him again
you